live on youtube
yeah no that's fine now chair you're
good to go okay that's fine
right okay good morning everybody to
someone that's uh internal meeting on
the 20th of april
um we will
begin because we have quite a bit to do
right apologies for absence kirsty
thank you chair apologies received from
councillor cottle honkin
okay thank you
right minutes of the last meeting uh
everybody's read the minutes i take it
i'll go through the pages three
four five
six seven
eight nine
ten eleven
12 13
and that's it um can i have a proposal
in a second
i propose so searcher yeah simon newton
proposed i'm happy to second
all right councilman manly second okay
casey could be going through a vote
thank you chair councillor belton at
four
mr dungate four
councillor dub four
councillor haims four mr harper
four chancellor inch
four councillor langford
ball councillor manly
paul councillor newton paul
councillor watson
mr chair okay thank you well item three
then we'll go on to
the action list which is on pages 14 to
15.
um okay
minute 69 that's still ongoing
um minutes 59
the response from major products and
estates manager is still ongoing
61. did somebody want to say something
no all right minute 61
uh and that's another response from our
projects and
estates manager that's still ongoing
uh minute 74 to review this well that's
that is on our agenda
and the cost of zoom meetings to be
circulated to committee members
sarah by sarah ayers i think we all got
that
yes or no yeah yeah
yeah okay yes sir
right we'll move on then
public contributions i don't think we've
got any have we
john richard sorry tom
that's correct right okay
declarations of interest item five you
all
understand about the declarations of
interest by now
so i won't go through all that
urgent matters um brought forward with
the permission of the chair i've got no
urgent matters
has anybody else got anything they want
to say anything about the the minutes
etc now
agreements between agendas part one and
two we have no part two
item eight we go on to uh grants
maintenance pages 16 to 20.
yeah councillor haynes has raised his
[Music]
yes um yeah i'm i'm a bit concerned
about this report because
on a number of occasions i've asked that
the
considerations of biodiversity and
climate change
should be part of the um review of the
um
maintenance contract or when we talk
about it coming in house and
in the uh implications at the end under
biodiversity and sustainability it says
none
well to me this you know this is highly
important our open spaces
in terms of fulfilling our our policy um
our carbon plan etc in terms of
creating extra areas of biodiversity
um looking at the impact of climate
change in terms of going over
to battery-powered equipment rather than
fossil fuel powered equipment
and also looking at the whole thing of
using
um chemical sprays whether we should
continue to do that or limit that
etc so you know i i really think that we
should
be saying something about um
the consideration of the contract should
um of uh the open spaces etc
uh should be done in in the context of
climate change and loss of biodiversity
and uh there should be a full input from
the climate change working group okay
where's sean carney yeah i'm your chair
i can respond
to that if you like yes yeah the the
implications table in the report there
is in relation to this report to this
committee
um those matters that that council
haines
just brought up will of course be
considered as we move forward with the
project
but they won't be considered at this
committee under this report
so that's why they're not listed there
it's not to dismiss their importance at
all
sorry chair this no this this committee
has the opportunity to put as our
part of our response that you know that
we should make that observation
and make that requirement that there
should be full input from
um the working group the climate working
group really
i'm sure that you will take that into
consideration because
obviously there's a lot more work got to
be done on this because
it looks to me as though we're looking
to take it in-house
that's right that's right yes so of
course really important considerations
yeah i mean this has got this has got
basically
a year to run yet with you know with
with us trying to organize it to stake
to come in house
so i'm sure all those all those things
will be taken into consideration
a point sorry chair can i
was it possible if i can add a point yes
you can steve yes sorry i missed you i
didn't see you there
that's okay if you look at page 18 on
the report
yeah um the third item up from the
bottom
indicates there's a monthly liaison
between this project
yeah and janet williams who obviously is
the office of support for the climate
emergency
working group yeah in relation to the
green agenda so that's the
link between this piece of work
and that working group so it's it's
already factored into that
that part of the work program chair
yeah i was going to mention that because
i thought i'd read it somewhere on this
report
why have you put none under
sustainability and biodiversity
implications
i think that comes back to the point
that i was making share that for this
particular
committee meeting and your decisions or
recommendations made today
it's unlikely that you're going to be
making their implications of this report
uh are on biodiversity and
sustainability those are factored in
elsewhere in the governance of this
project
that's that's i think the point if you
you may disagree i can put it in future
updates if you wanted to
but that's just the way it interpreted
it today i'd like it and updates please
yeah
yeah well we'll we'll go with we'll go
with future updates john
like a minute what i've said as well
thank you i think you it'll all be
minuted peter
okay thank you
right any more
okay anybody else want to say anything
about the grants maintenance
i think this is a good report to be
honest and i'm looking forward to
actually seeing it coming out
and i know that c and r uh
i think they've approved it to coming
out so yeah so
anybody else got any comment yeah
councillor langford's got a hand raised
oh shirley sorry thank you um
it's just a quick inquiry um
do on the grass cutting um do they ever
cut
grass that is um
not owned by um tdc
so in other words it belongs to housing
agencies and things like that
chair i think richard will know a bit
more detail on this one than me but i
think
we we do cut some spaces that aren't
owned by us
yes um but i can't tell you exactly
which ones
okay so do you enlighten us on that
richard
yes thank you chad um there are areas
that we do
um do regular graphs cutting off um
that will come out as part of the the
project plan um
as you can see in the timeline we're
looking to start that in june
yeah and part of that will be to have a
clear
better understanding of our estate what
we do who does it
to reduce the duplication of the town
councils along with perhaps
the community club such as the rugby
club um
as well as local residents undertake
what they class as
pieces of no man's land of which um we
provide
the garden waste collection for because
they're doing them you know the local
service
they're in the minority but uh obviously
as we get through the program
that's where we'll be clearer on who
does what
uh how often um and do we really need to
and that will be a decision for members
going forward
okay thanks richard just can i ask just
ask one thing very quickly then
do you happen to know richard if um
um tivoli cut the bowden green park or
is that done by westwood housing or
don't you have that information
richard i don't have that i don't have
that information right now but i can get
it for you very
well at the end of this week okay that'd
be brilliant thank you so much
thank you chair ian harper would like
just just a couple of points obviously
there's a lot of capital involved in
this
when is the time for repayment back for
that capital
and also are we looking to utilize the
um
facilities we got to go out and make
this an economic
income generator okay sean
as we currently stand to the second part
the first part i
i don't know the answer to i'd need to
i'd need to find out richard might have
a better clue than i do
um in the second part as we currently
are setting things up
no um there might be an opportunity to
to look to that in the future
but the way we're progressing at the
moment is primarily
to service whatever we are currently
looking after within this current grants
maintenance contract
given those caveats that that richard
just made there that the members will
obviously have oversight you might want
to
to change things around a little bit but
we're not looking at we're not looking
at setting up a business
i think in a nutshell right okay
do you want to make any other comment
richard
um no not this moment chad i can answer
questions
um you've all got the report before you
and the project plan but what what
i've learned over the years especially
with bringing the recycling in the house
is
you know the 12-month extension that
that we've got now
with tivoli you know what we've done
before is it reduces duplication and
we're able to
manage customer expectation better and
have more control of what we're actually
doing
yeah and be more timely it will give us
a better understanding of our estate
and we can be more reactive um
and it will give us a time which you say
from june
right through we will have the time to
report to members
to give them a range of options of what
they would like
um as well as you know costed models for
each option
yeah which ultimately underpins
everything
um with regard to purchasing of
machinery it would
initially it was going to come in house
for this
financial year that's changed obviously
we work for a short period on
understanding and assessing what
equipment
and scoping out and for councillor
haynes as well
i've looked at costing out a whole range
of electrical
equipment as well um and how
viable they would be using uh be able to
be used
um and it also gives us time to
as well as the more specialist of the
the tree surveys and the cemeteries
uh and and the pest control you know
which where that
sits uh most efficiently in each
department
um and whether that's externalized um
but no that's about it sorry
um
this is just a heads-up report and i
accept that and therefore it's not
really the time for for wanting to ask
any detail
when do we expect it says here that
they'll report periodically
when do we expect to see a report which
has actually got the
the detail of the plan in it so we can
actually really sort of um
have we got a timeline for that because
until we've got that then people's
question
there's no point really asking detailed
questions people got to get on and put
it together
yeah richard sean
which one
so chad in in the project timeline that
there are
there are a series of reports to
different uh places in terms of
smt project uh property major projects
things like that
so so i've tried to explain a little bit
about the governance process for this
project
um in the in the sect in the last
section the conclusions section of the
report
um i don't have a specific date of when
the detail
of the forward proposal
will be uh produced but it will be
produced
to property and major projects working
group in the first instance
because that will be the working group
that will sort of have
oversight of this project as it pushes
towards its conclusion
um so i can't really add to that
we can we can work towards adding a date
into the timeline
if you want yeah if you wanted one sure
why if i may ask why are you
waving this report in front of us then
if it if we are not
actually the the the committee that owns
the function
uh chair through the chair a bit because
i was asked to
cancel newton um it was something that
you had on your forward plan that you
wanted
oversight of the process yeah yeah okay
and so
i think we need to be chair i i think
we've got to be
i would have thought we need to be
careful about um starting to
overlap into other committee's business
if it's not if it's not our
if we don't own it um in that sense then
um
i'm not quite sure that we should be
busying our time
in effect interfering in another
committee's business era
but there's no reason why we can't be
kept updated
yeah i mean that's a financial aspect
financial side of it yeah
yeah yeah then we should have the
opportunity to look at it
yeah that is the reason for bringing it
to us is the finance side
yeah one uh presumably okay thank you
so if sorry steve steve do you want to
come in
joe manley wanted to come in i don't
know where she is uh
thanks jay um i guess councillor newton
uh picked up what i was going to say
it's
you know at the end of the day once we
have the fully
the service fully specked up as an
internal service
there there will be the cost stations
the budgetary implications
which obviously your committee has
oversight
of um obviously it'll go through
community resources as a final
decision and a final set of proposals
and then
um you know scrutiny has that role to
play in
uh the budgetary process thereafter so
that's kind of the bit of the role
okay that's that's fine steve good good
joe joe manley where
where are you joe
she had she had a random and disappeared
okay
peter ames what what you want thank you
yes on this time on this time sheet here
we've got
august we're coming to internal scrutiny
is that right
yeah yeah because it was just being
asked what
by councillor newton yeah
i don't think that will be with the
fully specced up no no
but it could be it would be an update
for us though sean won't
it yeah yeah that's fine mate that's
fine
phil pennington do you want to say
something
just a couple of questions here thank
you page 19 bottom lead member of you
councillor hicks i didn't realize he's
the lead member for property is
is property now another lead member uh
nation that's been put in there and just
for somebody who doesn't follow council
politics very well
when was it actually decided to take it
in house because
you know the way it's worded by our lead
member it seems like
a decision was made but i can't remember
which committee that was you
it was made at so just wonderful i think
it was cnr
you know was it thank you i think it for
saying thank you chair
john was that right yeah i can't
remember the dates off the top of my
head but we'll need i
i can if you put it on the action list
i'll make sure it's updated circulated
there yeah yeah okay that's fine
it was a full council decision actually
when we were
it was when we were reporting an update
on the the two major contracts that the
council has yeah that's right it was
full council is there a lead for
property only now
it's as written here or is it is that
because coaster hicks i thought
economy not for property
on the bottom of a page 19 last uh lead
member of you
yeah i can i can see it phil i i haven't
got a clue there i
i thought it was for the economy but
does this come under bobbix as well
steve
yeah thanks yeah so we uh um i say we
you
reviewed the the lead member roles which
again were reported to
full council yeah some time ago
and uh councillor hicks covers
economy and property uh in terms of
the way the the the the council's
organization
our structure sits okay
thank you claire
right now i was just going to reiterate
what steve
said we had a reconfiguration of the
lead member roles
and uh it felt that
the portfolio of services that
i was actually lead member for was uh
you know too large and we changed that
lead member role to
focus on finance and property
went to uh bob hicks so
and there were some other changes with
regards
to some of the other roles so yes
it has been and it was agreed at full
council so
thanks for yeah okay any more questions
on this
i think we're a bit bit early with this
report to be quite honest
but there's a recommendation that we
note the content
so is everybody agreed do everybody
agree that we note the content
of this report and we received periodic
progress reports
everybody agree with no need to have a
vote yeah
yeah yes yeah okay
yeah we'll move on
okay we're gonna look at
item nine now the qbr
uh that we did at test and finish group
and
simon has actually volunteered
to give us a give us a talk on this
haven't you simon
where are you or have you gone you know
what it's like when you're
when you're stood just thinking about
something and trying
to keep out the limelight and somebody
gives you one hell of a big push from
behind and uh
you stagger forward into the circle well
uh
um yeah i agreed that uh i i would
i would open it and then very quickly
hand over to the subject matter expert
so
make make
so um speaking on behalf of the task and
finish group
um loyal little band we actually i think
i can speak on behalf of them we enjoyed
doing this
together with um the
uh officers who supported us uh variably
and um but we did enjoy it and it was
it was a job that needed doing um
first slide please
right okay and
next the uh no hang on and the
the um the issue was just go back
at one please right and the issue
really was to identify what the issues
were
with the qbr why why were we looking at
it wasn't just a routine review but that
was
something that we needed to get at and
we were concerned that
as a as a publication as a document
it wasn't been read widely enough or
understood widely enough
or there wasn't any enthusiasm to want
to look at it
or indeed understand it and it it needed
to be
more better and more accessible than a
specialist
ninja document uh that only people who
count beans and
and uh really understand the inner
workings
we'll look at um and we wanted
to uh try to make it
basically more readable and more
understandable so that
not only a wider breadth of members
who aren't involved in these specialist
committees but also
indeed because it's a public document
the general public
more people may pick it up and actually
want to look at it and then
could have a chance of understanding it
um
so that was the first thing and then
secondly for our own
purposes we wanted to make it a more
effective
and a sharper tool for tracking and
monitoring
what we're doing here in council next
slide please
and there are there's two parts
to it one was the structure
and the other is the content um
the structure obviously is the visual
aspect of it
and how it flows how easy it is to hang
on in there and stay with it
and and is it logical and then
the content is of course the detail the
meat
uh of actually what is it that it's
saying
um so
we
we picked certain criteria that we used
um that we went through and you can see
here on this slide
we looked at from its size to
um how accessible was the key
information that
people needed to see um
could we actually track progress um
or was it just a same old thing coming
up um and lastly
probably most rel uh most most
importantly relevance
um was
what was being said did it need to be
said uh or were other things
not there um let's start just by
go next slide please
right and to give you an example of flow
obviously above the line is what we've
got at the moment
where you've got pretty basic four
quarterly reports
come straight to us we wanted it
to be much better linked right away back
to the strategic plan
so you therefore had a left to right
flow that somebody could follow
and they could pick out our strategy and
then
see that translated into service and
business plans
and then the so what in other words what
measures and actions
came out of those plans and then
incorporated
into the report because the report is
only
of an action the report doesn't stand on
its own
it has to be of something else and then
it comes to us so you have a much better
flow
which you can track right the way back
to the
strategic plan yeah and to do that
in ins i mean a very simple thing
we turned the report from being
published in
in um portrait um
format landscape format so that there
was more space
for things to flow left to right and you
weren't having to flick things onto a
different page
next slide please
and to give you
an example of how we challenged each
part there
is how the in very basic terms the
existing qbi
used to be set out and we challenged
everything
in it
more importantly we tried to put the
emphasis
on how the reader saw it um
not how the contributor saw it so
we we tried to put the emphasis on how
the other member or member of the
general public or whatever who is not
necessarily a um
of a or acquainted with looking at this
sort of stuff
how they would see it uh as
not um how our finances etc would
they would routinely put things and we
found several examples
of terminology that was being used
frequently
within the sort of specialist financial
area
which actually didn't make any sense to
a member of the public
so we've changed the terminology in
certain things
in order to hopefully be more
understandable
next slide please
so my last slide here um
and from and before i then hand over to
the specialists who will take us through
it but
these are the main comments that we came
up with general comments
general comments they're going to lead
you into detail in a minute
and um so um
this is just very very overarching stuff
as i've already said we needed to make
it more readable
and to accept that
this document ideally needed to be
accessible to as wide a
number of people as possible and its
structure needed to be logical
uh it needed a full audit trail
back from the strategic plan left to
right
flow across the page um
we needed current year targets
um his we didn't want it full of history
that's a distraction um so
we want to know what are the targets
and then how how are we doing now and
projected
against those targets um
more detail then committee members
can acquire that through the q a process
and that's partially why this committee
exists
to actually interrogate the report
through
looking at the report when it's
processed
and putting forward detailed questions
but if we try to put all of that in the
initial report
then the report just gets too big too
wildly and the
key material gets buried
um we wanted greater emphasis
when the when the report flags something
in other words it appears in red um one
thing we did learn
is that our key finance officer um
david is colorblind and therefore um uh
it's a bit
bit disconcerting um when we've got um
financial reports where we've got things
in red and green um
whereas to david it was it it was almost
it's all the same
um the um anyway
so we needed greater emphasis
when something was flagged as to what
was
what was gonna happen about it um
and the next point is something that
actually we would
consider should be um adopted
more cross council pan council
everything really should have some form
of
value because in these committees
what we're doing is we're measuring
things
without we have to measure things in
order to be able to compare
and make an a judgment on their progress
um and that measurement as it says that
can be financial
time numeric um
but things need to be have a value
against them
because being blunt you cannot
um monitor something properly
unless it has a value and then that
value can be compared against
target
we've had a discussion and no more than
that
and it's one down track but we've had a
discussion
on the need to measure or find a measure
or create a measure
probably needs us to go and talk with
other councils funnel enough to see if
other people have
how other people have done it how do you
measure social value
and we think this is very important
actually but
it's not it can't be just
subjective for each member to
measure it in their own view we need
some form of criteria
by which we can create a measurement
otherwise it's impossible
to to apply it in a meaningful way
no data or a blank
box will be interpreted
as a failure of the
member or officer who is asked to fill
that box in the future
if we ask for information
we expect it to be provided because if
we don't have that information
we cannot do our job so
i apologize for sounding tough on that
line but
um we will require up-to-date data
when we're doing things there are
occasions when
we come across something and it's just a
blank box well
you know if if there's nothing to say we
need to be told that
a blank box tells us that whoever was
responsible for it
just hasn't got around to actually doing
it um
budget monitoring we had a long
discussion and a lot
a lot of uh input from david on this um
and it's this is the relevance bit
and if you look at that bullet budget
monitoring and the one below
the need to introduce percentages is how
we actually
monitor variance within budgets
and um it's to do with scale and we get
we get lost in a lot of very
small variances from projected budget
and actually that's inconsequential
and we've been distracted by it and we
need a system
which flags major variances
i there's something going on here uh
councillors sit up
pay attention um there's something
happening here that you need to be aware
of
um because uh the trend is not good
and therefore you will see when we get
through to it
that actually budget variances will now
be
um first of all listed as a percentage
of the original um budget uh
target and secondly they'll be listed in
order of variance so therefore the big
variance will be at the top of the list
and the inconsequential insignificant
thing
will be at the bottom so you only need
to look at the top ones really to see
where the big problems are and
lastly we need to see um
more a detailed breakdown of investments
including of course the ethical
investment
uh i'm stopping there that's more than
enough from me time to hand over to
um our subject matter experts
and the real detail um thank you simon
you did a brilliant job mate who's who's
on first then
it's me chase john all right john go for
it man
yeah thank you next slide please
and thank you to councillor newton how
do i follow that
really good thank you with great
difficulty absolutely
i'm gonna just do a couple of slides and
we'll go on to david
um he'll come back to me then to chris
and then it will finish with the chair
so as councillor newton said um the
proposed new style is to
to be in landscape and you'll have a
full example on your agenda
but just to show you on this page what
it what it looks like
and again you'll see that it is linked
to our new
strategic plan with all the themes of
the strategic plan
if we go to the next slide please
what what the working group have
recommended
is that they continue with the
performance highlight
they it's going to be slightly different
format
just hopefully a little bit clearer and
um made to look so that it's easier to
read
and again link to the strategic plan and
that will be the theme that you'll
you'll note going through this whole
presentation
if we go to the next slide please
we are um also um going to
continue with the budget monitoring
pages these are a few
of the existing uh budget monitoring
pages
and david will go shortly through um
the new budget monitoring pages and
explain
kind of how we got to to what we've um
what the working group are proposing if
we go to the next slide please
it's just give you an idea of what the
current one the existing qbr budget
monitoring pages look
like and the next slide please
again this is part of the existing one
where
you have the earmark reserves and the
investments let's go to the next slide
please
david will go um and just explain to you
now
what we're proposing and what the
working group are proposing for the
the new budget monitoring pages
uh thank you john how do i follow that
um
can i have the next slide please
um okay this one actually unfortunately
it's not a great one to start with
because this one
is actually largely unchanged so far and
the income monitoring is
in a very similar format to what i had
before however if i just take you down
to where it's got the salary monitoring
one of the
key things that came out from the
working group if you look in there we've
actually got the funded establishment
and also the vacancies that we're
carrying
and that's information that wasn't
previously available so that's at the
bottom of the
slide um we ignore the vacancies in
refuge mainly because what happens if
somebody's a driver or a loader
is um leaves the organization we would
always backfill with agency so it
doesn't really generate the savings or
such actually actually probably cost us
more
sometimes to have agency staff so that's
just to give you the context there
that's what the budget is where we spent
against budget
how many people we did in the funded
establishment and what the level of
vacancies that we're carrying that was
obviously a large contributor
to any vacancies that we have at that
time um the next slide please
this one now is actually a more
fundamental change from where we were
before
so we've got as councillor newton said
we've
highly we've put the variances in order
of magnitude
and we're on the left hand side we've
got the old benz and on the right hand
side we've got the underspends and
in this case at the end of september the
two matched so let's just take
um the first if you go to where it's got
um contribution to the shortfall in
capital funding it's the 642 000 we're
going to contribute into what to our
capital budget
uh as a percentage budget that's not
applicable i we didn't set a budget to
do that we've done that because the
finances have allowed us to do that so
that's not irrelevant
however the next one is so we've got car
parking income
517 000 pounds overspend or under
achievement of income
which is actually 37 to the budget so
obviously a very significant variance
both in
degree in terms of the percent of the
budget and also in terms of its actual
quantum of 517 that's quite clearly
as at the end of september that's
because we had the lock down in
april may june of 2020 as a result of
the pandemic and obviously our
income dropped remarkably um
then you see another one which is
probably a good one to observe the next
one down that says transfer to reserves
to fund council tax on business rates
losses realizable in 2020 1 22
the magnitude is large 336 000. but
actually as a percentage of the budget
it's very small it's only four percent
so i think that's the point that
councilman newton was it gives you some
context you've got one on the
one side the magnitude but as a
percentage of the budget not a massive
um difference so um
you know i won't go through through the
list adam for an item
i mean maybe just choose one for example
just go a little bit further we've got
legal professional fees 100.
well that's a 330 percent variance
against a budget well that was the
court case at skern lodge that's what
we'd set aside oh okay
the case was settled early and in our
favor so
subsequent to that that that adverse
variance isn't
that magnitude at all but that gives you
an indication well
what is that how come legal fees are 333
above budget that's because we had a
very significant legal case ongoing at
that juncture
um and if you look over to the right
side and say well we've got all these
overspends how come we're balanced how
come the overspends meet the underspent
if you look on the right hand side and
as council newton says just go to the
top of the page
well there's the answer front of house
isn't it
the kovid related grants are 1.4 million
and the compensation scheme for a loss
fees and charges of 342
000. so it gives you the context i hope
it does anyone i certainly think
and the input to the working group has
highlighted that what we presented
before wasn't in a user-friendly manner
and i personally think this is a
significant improvement i do thank the
members of the working group for guiding
us down this route
could have the next slide please
okay
sorry i'm just going to look on my
computer screen because not only am i
colorblind but my eyesight
is appalling so this is a budget
narrative
so it starts off with the headlines the
headline figures are projected surplus
of 642 000 it is recommended that we put
set this aside to
meet the funding shortfall in the
capital program so the answer's
front of house then there's a little bit
of an
allude to what the result of the
pandemic is on the council's um
finances and then these key significant
variances there
are extracted below so it's like even
more summarized version
of the sheet that's gone before with a
little bit more narrative so for example
um car parking income i have just
explained it before so if you look on
the
carpet this is due to the national
lockdown that was in fact from april to
june
so on the previous page you have the
quantum 517
000 you know that it's 37 on the next
page on the budget narrative
it just gives you that little bit more
details it says well why is that
happened
okay so that's and it's only really as
counseling we focus on the key
items okay next slide please
right this one was a probably the the
capital one i would suspect was one of
the ones that was
slightly more difficult so what happens
with capital course we have the budget
for the
this current financial year which also
include any capital slippage from the
previous year
and if you look at say um just there on
vehicles we've got 727
000 the second line down the vehicles
and we've spent 38 000
that doesn't tell you anything because
you don't know when the vehicles were
scheduled to be
replaced and then so what we decided to
do is down below is give a narrative to
give some context to that
so probably the easiest one to
understand is the property and
infrastructure capital budgets over
seven million pounds
we spent 121 000 well what's the story
behind that
well the main story behind that is it's
5.6 million set aside for
a new environmental center and we
haven't secured a site
so until we see security site we can't
incur the expenditure
it was budgeted to be spent this year
perhaps really
with hindsight we probably should have
in our capital program set that a year
forward
but that gives members the context of
why we've
spent so little of the capital um and
then i think the next one down
regeneration is 1.2 million we only
spent 118 000 but the narrative
tells you well works are ongoing at the
new borough center so cost will have
been
will be incurred late in the financial
year 2020 21
when actually probably some of the costs
will slip into 2021.22
next slide please
uh then we just um wanted to show you
the earmark reserves our members knew
what we'd set aside in earmark reserves
and i think the main thing there was to
emphasize to members
how much is actually set aside for the
capital
you know there's over we've got amount
reserves out of
just under nine million pounds but
actually over five million is set aside
for our capital program
which is we've already alluded to is
under resourced
and then uh we've down below we've set
aside of the the
earmarked revenue reserves we've listed
some of the the larger ones so members
have some insight there's lots of
reserves
and we thought we'd give members a bit
of an insight so the biggest one is the
transition in government funding reserve
that's what's what allows us to balance
our budgets
uh over the meet the life of the medium
term financial strategy over the next
four to five years so there's a gap in
the budgets
of say two hundred thousand we'll take
two hundred thousand out of the
transition government funding reserve
to make the budgets balance until such
time as we can bring the budgets on an
even keel
and then there's the local plan inquiry
reserve members are following aware that
you know we've always got to update the
local plan and they incur
significant costs in terms of
sustainability plans and we have to go
out to consultants to
produce these plans for us in the main
so that's what we
just expanded on now the bottom one on
the investments what you had before we
just told you how much we had on deposit
essentially
well members of the working part said no
we want to actually see
what's on deposit with who for how long
and the interest rate that we get and
whether it's
an ethical investment now the next time
you see a qbr you will see
ethical investments so we've we have
made our first ethical investment
so you'll see that we've made an effort
so
you just got a bit more detail so you
get told what's on deposit who it's with
how long it's for when it terminates and
whether it's ethical
or not and members of the working of
sort of internal overview and scrutiny
going forward can ask the question
why if our policy is ethical by default
unless it
reaches and becomes too costly the
questions as for an internal scrutiny go
why is only one of them an ethical
investment why isn't the majority of
them an ethical investment then it's for
me
in my role at internal scrutiny to
explain why that would be the case
so there's more information available to
you i think that's the last
finance life but if you move on to the
next slide yes that's the last finance
slide
back to you john i believe yeah before
we go on do
anybody want ask david any questions
nope okay right
who we've got next is it chris it's me
you know it's me chair to start with
oh it's huge right
okay so just just as a little bit of a
recap this is the existing qbr
for for the actions and and the measures
and this is a this is a real one this is
a stronger safer
healthier communities so it's just as a
recap now
um this is how it looks if you go to the
next slide please
uh and this is the existing one now also
with um the measures so you'll see now
we've got some measures
and what when we looked at this with the
working group we're saying oh yeah let's
have a look at that
well there's some red there well where
do we see why is it red
okay next slide please well we have to
go
over the page to read the notes to find
out
why it's red okay well that's one of the
reasons
why the committee wanted or suggested it
went to landscape so that we could make
that clear so if we go to the next slide
please
you'll see once again on another page
will be the notes on the red performance
of the existing ones so if we go to the
next slide
so this is when we'll move on to
the new format let's go to the next
slide please
and what you'll see again it's all
linked to
our strategic plan so we're going
everything's going from left to right
and these are specifically from from the
strategic plan
um there's a progress there's a rag
status
and there's the overall position so
you'll see now that
the actions in the qbr
flow directly from the strategic plan
and into kind of a very clear position
statement for members and the public to
see
very clearly um councillor newton
mentioned before
we need to be smarter with our
terminology
and um and of the the information we
provide
in this uh document so that we are very
specific
we go to the next slide please
you'll also see uh for the measures
you'll see now
um the example i gave you previously
they were listed but we had to go down
to the next page or the next page but
two to see why um
they'll read the notes and and to see
why
they were read now once again they go
from left to right
it's very clear the actual um notes will
explain
um right next to the actual measure
itself so
uh the working group considered that to
be a lot clearer
and much easier to to read
to understand and then to to quicker for
the document to be read as well because
it's all it's all in one
one place go to the next slide please
again another example real life example
from
from a previous qbr but as you'll see
it's very clear um to see how that
performance is is
going and the reasons behind it okay
if you go to the next slide please
yeah thank you and the next one so it's
just it's just a
live example so as part of
the changes i'm going to hand over to
chris in a second but as part of the
changes
and to allow for the improvements that
you've just seen
um there was a suggestion from the
working group to take out some of the
um previous information that was in
the qbr and that was some of the the
historic three four five year
year old data so what the working group
group has suggested is that instead of
having that on
every single qbr um
that we produce a trend analysis on a
on a yearly basis that's appended to
qbr4 now we we will have that
information to hand
throughout the year so if members won't
want that information
um as part of a specific uh query that
they've got on any of the qbr's they can
just raise that under the question
and answers and we can provide it but uh
the the working group considered that it
would be much clearer and much
um better to have this at the end
end of the year so chris will now go go
through
and show you what um the proposal is
for this trend of our analysis
thank you john as john was just saying
um the old qbr format had this um three
years of data
um historical data which we're taking
out and also historically the
qbr one two and three um
had less measures in there and qbr4
always has like more
additional measures in there we want to
make it so the qpr one two three four
the same size
and the detail stuff is in this addendum
um
so this will propose that qpr4 will have
an addendum
um this will kind of provide you with a
full set of performance measures
at the year end it'll give you a full
six year trend analysis
so grab the next page please
and what we're purchasing here is
basically the um measures will be in
alphabetical order by service so he's
defined things
so the publish alongside qpr4 um
again it reads right to left so it's
easy to read it's in data order across
the page
we've put 60 years data in there we
probably could go to seven if we wanted
to but six years is quite a good trend i
think
we've kept in their target against
current year actuals
so we've kept them at amber green at the
end for the current year
we've given some kind of simple trend
graphs as well
so example on the next page thank you
if you look in the middle of the page
complaints um
any 260 entering time for complaints
handling you see that goes about 2015-16
when our turnaround was 19 and a half
days you see each year
going across from left to right has been
a gradual improvement
in our performance actually 2021 the out
turn is
15.6 days so again a slight improvement
and the target is actually 28 days
for the council so that that one is
green still
you can see on the right there's a kind
of trend graph just showing the trend as
it's actually a gradual reduction
in our performance um
let's say we kept the red number green
in the um
in qbr4 you will still have the key
measures in there with comments against
them
so you'll still have the comments in the
qvr4 this just gives you extra
information
and again if members want to ask us
question about the trends they can still
go through the q and a process
after a question uh next page please
and this just shows an example of if you
look at housing where there's no data in
there
that's because these were new measures
in 2018-19
so it's just saying historically they
started in 2018-19 was starting through
parts of the measure so there's three
years data for this one
as you go forward they'll obviously add
up to three four five six years
then start going forward again so we've
tried to keep it simple
try to make it easy to read we think by
putting this out of the qbr
having a separate document it makes the
whole thing more readable
i think that's it back to you john i
think
thank you chris so go to the next side
please
so i've just got a couple of slides just
to to um explain the kind of the summary
of the recommendations from the task and
finish group
um i guess i should have should have
just explained that that
uh for those of that didn't know the
task and finish group consisted of
council of
watson councillor newton councillor
langford mr dengate and councillor
haynes
um chris uh david and myself
kind of um helped uh facilitate the
working group
so the general changes that they've done
to summarize you you've had most of this
already
to align the qbr actions with the new
strategic plan
providing update and a progress column
to provide a full audit trail
straight back to our strategic plan i
think i can't
express enough how important members
felt it was to make sure that we
are monitoring our strategic plan
and i think that came across um very
clearly at
our task and finish group meeting they
lay out to be
landscape rather than portrait and i
hope you could see
in the examples we've given you um how
how that has improved
the layout and and the logic behind that
um they're proposing that we removed the
previous year's comparison columns
uh felt that those were distractions and
produce an end-of-year addendum that
chris has just shown you
uh shows trends and patterns um
we've able to move the notes of red
performance alongside the relevant
measure
easier to understand and read
and then the notes should be concise and
qualified
and we'll be working with our officer
colleagues to
to to help facilitate that going forward
and um we removed the um monthly figures
as a working group consider those as a
distraction
uh next slide please
there's sev david's gone through um
these with you
but it was proposed uh previous year's
comparisons again
columns from income paid these were
distractions
include the previous year's comparison
in the end of year addendum
as chris mentioned move notes
on income to the relevant role again
easy to read and understand
change total to actual in in column
headings
um add a forecast column so we can see
where we
be at the end of year position check the
income we are reporting at anything
that's missing so we've looked at
adding green waste to the stats and i
think it was some
some hospital costs
change some of the headings under the
salary monitoring
reorder their variances with the largest
at top
provide more detail for the earmarked
reserves
revenue reserves and for the ethical
um and all the investments including the
ethical
information we were to short-term
deposits try to make it clearer and more
understandable
not just for us but for the public as
well we moved back it's a bit
clear about overspend and underspend and
um kind of add a narrative to the ear
mark reserves
uh dave has dated david showed you about
adding the trade states and ethical to
the investment
and um we've sought some columns around
to make it
make it flow better let's go to the next
slide please
um there's a few more that we looked and
i think you hopefully understand i mean
the working group had four meetings um
several of them went on um for a
considerable length of time
um it was a very thorough working group
and i
hope you can kind of appreciate how much
um information and work that's gone into
this um
there was some changes to the highlights
page and i showed you that at the very
start and
the narrative and there were some
changes to the measures so um
we've we've taken out the employment
rate
um because it was the government model
and we've replaced with two
new measures by the number of people who
are not in employment claiming universal
credit and the number of people who
are in employment and claiming universal
credit the working group considered
those to be
more relevant um measures
um again looking at uh the employment
rate should be in
in the trend summary uh at the end of
the year
uh it was it was suggested that we
include the um
timely payment of invoices as a measure
to show
kind of the the support we've given to
our local businesses
uh similarly uh the number of businesses
entirely should be included in the
annual summary of trends
so we can get a feel for how the economy
is
is going um
we we looked at early 352 and didn't
which was accidents reported on council
premises and and
looking at the the stats for that the
working group didn't think that was a
necessarily a um a measure that needed
uh reporting on a regular basis
and they said you know if there was an
issue then that would be reported in
other ways
um we uh the working group looked at a
measure for
achieving the carbon neutrality so we've
got the target
to to do that by 2030 and
um we received something from janet at
the end of last week
and they are proposing two measures for
that
um that she's um found on the government
website so those will be coming
um to the um
uh or to the qpr soon as available
uh it was a suggestion to take out the
two um
bv 82a dry recycling rate and the cost
compost inmates but add two new ones in
about the tonnage uh for garden waste
and food waste because it was felt that
they would give
a more uh clearer understanding from the
members of
of actually rather than a percentage is
actually actually you'll see
that their figures are are increasing
rather than percentages
of a percentage which were some of the
other ones and then there was a
some suggestions of uh changing uh
or moving some of the measures to
different themes
now the the working group went into lots
of detail
um you have got a copy of all or the the
final
um version um and i believe you go to
next slide please
yeah so that that's me done i'm going to
pass you back to the chair
myself david or chris um happy to uh
answer any questions uh as are
the members of the wrecking group yep
thanks for all that guys
you've done well there uh really i'm
really impressed
with how it looks it's probably the best
it's ever been
to be quite honest um has anybody got
any questions
and for john and david and
chris hello everybody can i
ask pete yeah uh
i was i was good actually just from an
experience point of view
uh and having seen it all before and
also from it
from his uh his previous finance
position i was gonna ask steve what his
view was of it
right okay steve um
thanks chair thanks [ __ ] newton i was i
put my hand up to make some comments
um i was intending to wait for members
of the committee to make some comments
first i have got a couple of comments so
i'm happy to do them now happy to wait
till after the
members have made comments it's up to
you chair no you get you you carry on to
the
while you're all right thank you um well
i i concur with what you said i think
it's
uh a really excellent piece of work that
the task and finish group have done i
think it does make it look
uh really much clearer much more
understandable
for members of the committee and for
others who
may wish to to read it the only only one
comment i had and no it's not a
criticism at all
it's only something that we may you may
wish to consider add into it and
i know the the leader and the deputy
leader are on the call and council
hodgson has a hand up
it's just simply in relation to um
linking the strategic plan with the
the themes you've got you've got all the
the senior officers on here
i was just wondering whether it's an
opportunity to add the
the lead members in against uh
on the on the table um could really
demonstrate how
closely lead members and officers
are working together in tandem to
deliver the strategic plan
now i know it's something um councillor
james comes to the hot summer when
they're looking at the lead members who
are kind to
keen to kind of adopt
that kind of approach with lead members
being more involved
in strategy more involved in the
strategic performance
i think it might be something that's
worthwhile so then if things are
either going really well or if things
are not going so well
you may wish to ask your lead members
to make comments and or attend a meeting
um to discuss concerns okay
i think it's just perhaps um an
opportunity you may wish to consider
incorporating given that um the lead
members have recently been re
reviewed as we said earlier i know um
hunter james and hudson were keen to
kind of develop those
roles and that was shared at leadership
um
a month or two ago right okay steve so
other than that
i think it's a really excellent piece of
work we can talk about that uh
i've got some hands up actually dude
dude gob your face
thank you uh yeah i just wanted to say
thank you to everybody that is involved
it's an excellent plan
and very easy to understand i'm you know
even
i can understand it which is saying
something but i just wanted to say thank
you for everybody's hard work thank you
right claire oh thank you mr chairman
i i'm not going to comment on what steve
has already said because i think he's
laid that out very well
congratulations to all of you i know
uh many of you were involved in the
review of the constitution as well
and is an almighty piece of work and
this is really something which i think
is going to be a document that
everybody will be able to access and
understand so compliments over
the last slide where you'd actually
remove
certain measures the one and only thing
that i have
as a sort of comment or observation is
my concern is the
measurement of businesses in torridge
at the moment if we were in a normal
situation i think this would be fine to
leave it to
the addendum for um qbr4
but at the moment with the impact that
is unknown
about how many businesses are going to
fail
and what we are doing with our
strategic plan to make sure that
employment
and businesses are supported and
sustained
i think we need to keep that measure in
i think it's
something that will flag up for us as a
council
whether we need to look and review how
we're aiming
resources assistance etc um
but that measure could come in
as and when we needed it because what
we've tried to do is take away the
things that
they're there every every quarter but
we don't actually need some every
quarter
well so there are questions i mean
people can ask the question
even if it's not on the qbr
yes i i just yeah yes i do
and i i respect what you're saying but i
still think it's a measure that for
this year coming out of the pandemic and
the relaxation of lockdown
we need to be on top of and it needs to
be in the public domain
sending out a message that we are
monitoring
uh the impact that it's having so
thank you right okay thanks larry
whoever got first council pennington
thank you thank you thank you joe yeah
thank you yeah
congratulations to the the team that put
this together
um really good um i take council
newton's point at the beginning when he
was presenting
um and good to see a a member take a
lead like this i
congratulate him for taking a lead
members should be leading this council
so congratulations
for that from that point of view and he
picked up on the point about
financial value and social value and we
mustn't lose
the social value bit along the way and i
looked at the homeless figure i think
the homeless figure
previous in the report was quite high
there was a percentage in monetary terms
there
but there's a social value i don't know
how you measure that social value
something maybe you thought about the
future and just to comment on page 10 of
the report
really interested in the new measures
you put in there about the claimants for
universal credit for those in work and
not in work
um i noticed that uh torridge has been
hit harder
than the south west or the united
kingdom and it really does
emphasize our our situation here in
torridge
we've had a really bad effect on the
lower income groups within
torridge uh from that point of view and
it does raise
questions about our council tax support
scheme we've got the harshest of the
eight districts in devon
it's i find that quite shameful i have
to say that we still do that i highlight
that many times when i'm speaking
and this reemphasizes the fact there's
many households that have really
struggled just
to meet some basic bills in the last 12
months and i do find it difficult when
we have a situation of a low income
economy
and the harshest council tax scheme um
across a district for working age
claimants
thank you chair for letting me speak i'm
not on the committee
yeah joe mine was just a quick one as
well actually it was just you know a big
well done to all the offices that
actually put all this together
i know it was a long hard read but i'm
sure
taking the time to actually put it all
together was much harder and it's very
comprehensive and
anything i think that makes it easier
for us to
be able to digest the information is
great because like everybody we're all
really busy
and um taking the time and when it's in
an easier format it's it's really good
to see
so i'd like to say thank you okay thanks
joe
peter ames where are you thank you chair
yeah just to
obviously congratulate the officers for
all our hard work and also councillor
newton
for his work and presentation um just
want to
reinforce what councilor hudson said i
think we should keep in the um
figures about um businesses because
at the moment because the picture is
changing very
rapidly due to covid um and as to the
social value that
i think that's um obviously worth
researching there are i think there are
techniques
um ways of measuring which one can find
out about
um i think new zealand government for
instance has
policy of um putting a value on
well-being etc
so i look forward to the results of any
research on that
okay simon
yeah yeah if if i if i may pee can i
just
come up on it come back on a couple of
things could i could i going back to
steve some
very very fair comment um i i don't get
overly carried away about things being
member-led
um i i tend to
like it to be a balance with with with
people who actually are subject matter
experts know what they're doing
uh and i come from a school that says
that if people are given clear direction
in the first place then they should be
left to get on and deliver it
but anyway could i ask that perhaps a a
way of denoting lead members
is by putting their initials in after
the the um uh the
the the role of the officer involved
the reason i say that is that i don't
think if we're not careful we're going
to end up with with more text in the box
about who's responsible for it or what
what role it
is then actually i'm not interested in
that i wanted i want to see
actually what's been done and what's
happening um and so
it doesn't want to be a a cosmetic thing
um just to to sort of promote policy so
perhaps
for instance i'm just looking at one
here under planning manager and if it
had planning manager
slash and then just the initials of
whoever the lead was on that than that
thanks for bringing that up simon might
be a good compromise
going back to social value i would again
yes as peter haynes just said we
we need to do quite a bit of research on
this
it's it can't you can't just grab any
one
particular statistic like homelessness
or whatever that doesn't tell you
and also we need to guard against the
measure
being politicized in a way because it's
an easy target for people to
to to to devise that so it tells a
certain
tale in the way they want it telling um
so
it'll be very interesting to have a look
around to see what
there will be effective ways i'm sure
um but it'll be an interesting project
to do
thanks so much okay chris
thank you chair it's just a comment
about the um
number of businesses in college um we
took it out because
we only get that figure once a year from
the government so it's in the qbi every
quarter but never changes
so we took it out to the end of the year
because i thought that'd be more
relevant
as annual figure because we can't get it
during the year
right that's why it was taken out yeah
that's fine okay
anybody else want to say anything uh
before
well me personally i i've i've enjoyed
doing this
and what i found was that we had
uh regular and finish group meetings
every two weeks which made
life a hell of a lot easier because
if you have them too far apart you tend
to lose track
and and for any task and finish group
that we do in the future
i would like to think that we can have
a much regular uh much regular meetings
say
like every two weeks but um
as regards the recommendation
i'd like to propose that we we
we accept this recommendation
um remember to adopt the newly designed
qbi
etc etc and
could i have a second for that am i
allowed to second it
i'm glad you are oh
so have somebody who's not on the task
and finish group
please actually
yeah brilliant piece of work
um i think we should take a vote on this
yeah we most probably need to don't we
yeah
kirsty thank you chair councillor belton
for mr dungate
or councillor gov
for councillor haynes
oh sorry for thank you mr harper
councillor inch four councillor langford
four councillor manly ball
councillor newton four councillor watson
thank you that's unanimous chair that's
great
okay we'll move on then
no item 10 extra strategy
okay head of community this is
sean somewhere there aren't you
hello chair yes i'm here um thanks very
much
uh so that to the report you've got in
front of you provide you with a bit of
context as to how we've got
to uh to adopting the estuary strategy
the journey started back in 2012 as a
precursor really to the
uh to the brunswick wharf development at
that time
to try and get some more coherence into
how the the
the harbour was managed and and that
sort of spread out the sprawl effect
happened in the when we started looking
at what was going on in the harbour
then yeah but what happened further down
the estuary and it was concluded that
we should probably get some advice in
and have a wider estuary strategy pulled
together so
uh the the high level brief is included
within the report so what the
what the consultants were commissioned
to achieve in addition to the strategy
there was some management information
provided to the
uh at that time head of operational
services
um if who was managing the hardware
service at the time
uh the cost of the work that was done
last time was uh
in the region 35 000 pounds and there
was some reasonable
reasonably extensive public consultation
on the document at the time
and harbour board recommended its
adoption cnr cnr subsequently adopted
the document
and the the adopted document as of
august 2014
is there for you to consider now
obviously at the last uh meeting
some concern was expressed about whether
this document was
was out of date uh it's over to you
members to decide whether you think
that's the case and and wish to
recommend to harbour board that they
consider a revision of this document
thank you thanks john
anybody any oh yeah councillor ames
thank you chair yeah um i remember when
this came out um
i think northern put in comments to it
um but i did i think um
i i wasn't happy then about the emphasis
really um it seemed to
over emphasize recreation and um
against the valuable wildlife
um interest of the estuary and direct
and didn't seem to recognize strongly
enough that it's an ssi
um so um in those terms i think it
needs reviewing i think it's it also
in terms of the economic um
possibilities
in the history i don't think it was
terrible i don't know whether
any of it's been sort of acted on really
i mean they're very sort of vague
references or
recommendations but i think it would be
could be tightened up
really particularly on the use of
middle dock and yeah and other areas
if possible yellen and yellen key as
well
um i think it's true to say that um it
has a certain amount of weight in
planning as well
so if we're reviewing the local plan
and talking about things like climate
change and the environment then
this document needs to be sort of
modified or reviewed
yeah i think them at the same time so
yeah thank you
okay thanks peter anybody else yeah
can i respond yes you can steve um
sean apologies if it came over to the
feeling that the document might be up to
date i think
more what i was asking is how often we
go back to it review it you know look at
it and see how it informs
what we're doing and the actual um
context of how we take it i mean peter's
just mentioned
property and and kind of one of the
areas that you know
the local plan how it informs and and i
was more interested in
in some of the key accountability
um so for example 2.11
to 2.16
you've got any observations on how you
feel those have been achieved
um it's more of that that i had in mind
rather than necessarily looking for us
to
to be going for a new strategy
yeah i can i can respond to that i mean
much of your previous debate
uh on the last item explains the the
importance of
us trying to stick to our strategic
objectives and deliver those
it's a constant challenge uh to
to set a a strategic direction and stick
to it as a council because
opinions change uh immediate items pop
up
and and i would i would say it has been
quite challenging
to to focus activity in
the harbor and wider estuary around the
adopted strategy i think that that has
to be recognized
um in terms of the uh the strategy is
con
it's it's frequently referenced but i'm
not
certain that it is integral in our
decision-making processes so
i don't think that i if i'm brutally
honest i think we adopted
a strategy um it's referenced in several
different places it comes up a harbour
board
again we've mentioned it at planning but
i'm not certain that it's integral in
our wider strategic
plans okay thanks
ian
unmute
i understand exactly what shoulder said
but i think the trouble with this this
is a strategic document
it isn't an action plan and i think two
2.4 in the plan actually says
that there should be a an action plan
and 7.4
sets this out but this hasn't ever been
done
so there's two elements there if if
we should be revisiting this this um uh
strategic plan and actually putting some
action points to it
or as sean has said just now perhaps we
ought to cut
get it and actually make it viable to
what we're doing now
um i noticed the middle dock is being
developed or or
the potential to be developed well
surely then the fish stock which is
costing us
quite a considerable sum of money every
year that ought to be looked at
and the same as the harbour board is
costing a lot of money and clearly
the the with the plan itself the
strategic plan
it sets out a number of options of
cargos but perhaps that doesn't happen
in the future
so i think perhaps as we looked at the
qbr that we ought to be looking very
much more to the future
thanks joe okay thank you ian
anybody else want to make a comment
chair just
come back in sorry yes sorry steve
just sean just to pick up on that i mean
i i hear all that you're saying but i
think again i was
i think it's it's something that ian's
just mentioned you know
whether there's a framework that we can
have a bit like the qpr
where we can be monitoring some of the
the key actions that were
identified because i mean it's a really
good report obviously
we've invested quite a lot within the
report
um you know and and has it you know
it's seven years ago has it helped to
guide me from the policies that
we're looking at now are we able to to
see investment opportunities
you know tourism and business you know
if we are
using it more actively with a kind of
some kind of framework
would it help or or is that not the case
do you think sure
um yes i think perhaps uh a framework
might be useful i i think um
if you if you took a look at the
overriding principles within this
document
the sort of highest level principles
those wouldn't those haven't changed
and and it is the actions that need to
be developed
to come out of those and those aren't
necessarily captured in one place
and one one of the things that this
document was produced to help with was
the better management of moorings in the
harbour
well only recently have we adopted a
mooring policy more into facilities
policy
that came as a result of this discussion
around this document but it isn't
captured anywhere in relation to it
i don't think so perhaps a framework
would provide some context to how useful
this document has been
and and then coming back to mr harper's
point i think it
it really is about looking forward and
about trying to capture
uh those forward actions you know lots
of work has been done
over the years to try and develop the
harbor as a commercial proposition
and they've been um periodic successes
and then
back to sort of downturns in shipping
that the forces of those are kind of
beyond our control in many ways the
large
economic uh forces determining
whether biddeford is a commercial place
a commercial proposition it doesn't come
down to
you know the depth of draft or uh the
the the cranage charges and things like
that so uh but yeah i i think it's
an actual a more detailed action plan
moving forward would be useful
perhaps more useful than a revision of
the strategy
further consideration of the uh habitat
issues around the development of leisure
in the harbour certainly something that
should be
considered and and a framework to show
the impacts of the strategy and how it's
been used
might be a bad thing um it it's up to
you whether you wish to recommend
those um i'm not sure
how long it'll take to put together but
we can have a look at them
thanks i mean that that's more what i
had in mind when i
you know stephen what what do you what
what would you like to do would you like
to us to
set up a little group and look into this
a little bit further before we send
and then possibly that might help the
auburn board to look at it
in a better way i think so because we
did
you know we did go back to the hard ward
a couple of years ago and they've done
quite a bit on
the policies and things like that so it
just feels maybe if we
do some of this for them and then before
passing it to them it might help
and just give our input yeah i'm i'm
i'm up for that so bait it basically so
we
i don't know whether we should call it
the task and finish group but
um if well we'll call it a task and
finish group but we're not
um we'd only be doing this
to help the armor board
sorry uh and
yeah that we that we set up a task and
finish group
uh and are we going to have on it
yeah i'd like to be on it okay peter
aims can come back but you'll turn up
this time peter will yeah i only miss
one tonight
yeah out of four you don't tell us when
they're happening
right i'll i'll go on it uh
ian do you want to be could i be honest
as well yeah could i be honest as well
yeah so we've got three of us um
stephen happy yes anybody else would
like to be on it
chairman could i could i suggest you
want to be on it
well i'd love to i'd love to yeah it
would be amazing
no of course of course i'd get involved
in the process and i've got
quite a lot of back history with this so
i do understand some of the things that
are going on there
but i think it might be useful if the
lead member
and the chair of harper ward councillor
hicks were invited to be involved yeah
yeah that's fine
that's fine so if we go ian album
yourself
councillor ames stephen dengate did
anybody else set put around up no
no no okay well like in bobbix and
um who's on the arbor board what's his
name
yeah it's councillor x yeah yeah yeah
okay you've got councillor hudson with a
hand up
okay claire i did want to sort of jump
in before you got down to this
um just to say that my comments on
reading this strategy
well yes i think the framework as sean
has pointed out
is fine but factually there are a lot of
things that would need to be updated
because it misinforms the reader
as to the status of some parts of the
estuary
and i also note and i'd like
clarification please
um this is a joint strategy
with northern devon with north devon
um and should we not be consulting
with them and having some reputat
representation and the last thing is
we've got a joint working group with
north devon looking at
um the impact of coastal erosion
in the uh on along our coast and our
estuaries
um do we want to establish a link
between that group
and this working group well this working
group could
could send its findings to to that group
yeah but but my my thought is
that if we get too many people involved
it'll take far too long
well quite i do understand your problem
but
if this is a joint plan a joint strategy
uh
should should north devon not be at
least involved in it
would you i think you're right in that
respect i do i do appreciate that
but but mike my take on it is that
if we do this now and come up with
various things
then okay north devon can be then
be involved uh and this group that
you're
you're on as well so that we're just
going to want to look at
to see what needs to be done and go
through
i mean
i hear what you're saying counselor
watson so
i i won't say anything more you know
you've given me a a rationale for
disagreeing with oh fine thank you
so we'll we'll set up a working group
we've got the working group
um either sean can contact bob or
or i will makes no difference um and
i'll
we'll come back with a date yeah and we
might well
start and go through it and pick some
points out and then then we can involve
the arbor board
and sure gain he's got his hand up come
on i just wanted to confirm for you
that this i this document wasn't adopted
by north devon council they were only
sort of consulted to the process
they don't really have an active role in
in the management they're not
they don't have a barnstable harbor
authority the harder authority they have
is
is ilf um the foreshore lease so that
we actually lease most of the land so
most of the
the issues were more related to our
activity than they were in north devon
so it's not a formal
shared strategic document enough okay
that's fine sure
okay so we all agree then that
um that we'll we'll
we'll we we're gonna form this task and
finish group
and there's no need to send
any recommendations to the arbor board
we'll just set up a task and finish
group and then
and then come back with findings okay
happy everybody's gonna
not at once yeah okay yeah any other
questions
before we move on
no okay
let's get back to the agenda
right
oh consideration of the forward plan
right everybody
what you want to put on the forward plan
did it anybody want to speak
nothing on the phone well it is this
will be for june
uh we'll have vet we'll have one or two
things to come back on it in june anyway
but
anything else on the phone who wants to
put anything on the forward plan
okay i just i just put my my hand up
steve oh sorry yeah i i know or
ordinarily
um from from past experience that you
you generally have a session at the
start of um
each year to consider your
forward plan for yeah
okay whether you're proposing to do that
um
at your june meeting yeah we can we can
do that
then that gives people time then to come
up with what they want to go on the
forward plan
all right everybody happy
always yeah yeah
okay then so let your life at that rate
then
exclusion of the public and we've we're
finished
and i hope everybody who's watching this
on youtube have
really appreciated it